let's go to headlines number one bill de
blasio
the uh big dumb cantaloupe come to life
is overseeing a city that has plunged
into violence and anarchy a baby
a baby was shot in the stomach and
killed a couple days ago people are
dying every day
but here's what he's worried about from
de blasio it says to whoever vandalized
our mural on fifth avenue
nice try uh let's see we've already
fixed it the black lives matter movement
is more than words and it can't be
undone this is what this dumb
oaf is worried about people are dying
left and right he's focused on the mural
on the street
a mural which by the way isn't really a
mural can i just say
words spray-painted on the street are
not a mural
that is state-sanctioned graffiti let's
not let's not
uh do it the favor of calling it a mural
that's not a mural
murals have artistic value that doesn't
but either way artistic value or not um
it doesn't matter no one cares about
your stupid painting
you idiot number two here's a shocking
turn of events a few weeks ago a student
at texas a m claimed that he found
racist notes on his car
they said all lives matter you don't
belong here and then another one had the
n-word
he posted it online it went viral media
covered it etc etc
and so forth and then what do you know
who'da thunk
turns out he wrote it himself i am
floored i know you probably are too who
could have guessed
that the old racist note left on the
windshield thing would end up being
fake i mean it's only fake every single
time
who who could possibly imagine that this
one would be fake too
um here's here's how
ridiculous it's gotten that
hate crime hoaxes are so common
that there are now genres of them there
are identifiable
recognizable genres and everyone has
their own favorite
right like there's the uh there's the
this one the
racist note left on the car windshield
gambit
there's the racist graffiti oftentimes
sprayed on a garage
um or you know side of a house or
somewhere else there's the
uh racist note on the receipt
the fake racist note on the receipt
that's maybe my personal favorite genre
of of the hate crime oaks
uh there's of course the racist noose
obviously
um there's the racist uh
note on a starbucks cup is another one
and then there are then there are
sometimes people there's the
genre bending genre defying
more ambitious efforts like the jesse
smallette for example you know the thing
is
i appreciate the justice millets i do um
to have that ambition and to be a little
bit more inventive
although you know you you could argue
that his hate crime hoax was derivative
because all he really did was combine a
few of these other genres and throw them
together
in kind of a grab bag sort of way there
wasn't there wasn't much of a compelling
narrative there um but i appreciated the
effort i guess is what i'm trying to say
but really when it comes down to it uh
my thing is
no reason to get inventive you call me
old-fashioned but i
like these quaint you know little
cliched
genres uh so if you're gonna go with the
hate crime hoax i say
stick with the classics you know oldies
but goodies
um play the hits that's sort of my way
of looking at it and and
that's what this guy did here you know
he's just he's just doing them you know
going with the standard
note on the car type of thing not a lot
of effort put into it but that's okay
doesn't matter um any other things of
course
people on the left it doesn't matter how
obvious obvious it is
they'll accept it doesn't matter so uh
no reason to put some effort into it and
um
and usually we're good for about one a
week now from from at least one of these
genres
and uh you know it's it's it's so it's a
lot of fun a lot of fun
numbers but but remember america's
systemically racist okay
we we have actual genres of hate crimes
um
but america's systemically racist right
number three
i thought this was a was also a lot of
fun tweet from ilhan omar says
income inequality is the greatest
determinant of your health and life
expectancy
our economy needs to needs to work for
the many not the few
the really interesting thing is that you
know ilhan omar and the other
people in congress aoc you know other
members of the
of the squad uh as much as they talk
about income inequality and how
concerned they are with it
you know they're making 174 000 a year
as members of congress which is well
over a hundred thousand dollars more
than uh significantly more than doubled
the the uh the average american salary
so
they could lead by example and call for
congress to impose significant pay cuts
on itself
so that the salaries of of of our
congressional members
reflects the average american salary and
then at least you're you're doing your
own part
to solve the income and equality problem
but they're not doing that
funny enough you know they're not
interested in that
it's that's it and also ilhan omar um
she
apparently allegedly has been funneling
hundreds of thousands of dollars
from her campaign to her to her
husband's consulting firm
you know it seems like she's not only is
she not
doing things to solve the income
inequality problem
but she is going out of her way to
perpetuate
that problem uh by making her own income
all the more unequal to everybody else's
really strange how it works
i mean it's almost like it's all call me
crazy it's almost like these people
don't give the slightest damn about
incoming
income inequality at all you know it's
that you would you would almost think
that wouldn't you
number four and as the wheel turns
another name change is being demanded
this is from the washington post it says
uh the texas rangers team name must go
members of the texas rangers force
were violent agents of white supremacy
so texas rangers were next to go i you
know i i knew this was coming i saw this
coming
and what they're saying is that
texas rangers were you know white
supremacists
uh they were violent men uh they killed
native americans
so on and so forth which which by the
way they were violent men and they did
kill native americans
the only thing that you know oftentimes
is not mentioned
by the people who advocate uh things
like this
is that they were doing battle with um
indian tribes who themselves were
extraordinarily violent and in fact the
texas rangers would have been battling
the most violent indian tribes in the
entire country the plains indians the
comanches in particular
uh you know would as we talked about
last week
you know par for the course
standard operating procedure for tribal
at the comanches
was to um
invade either neighboring tribes or it
didn't matter if
you were it wasn't like they were just
lashing out against white expansionism
no they would they would treat you
whether you were a white outsider or an
indian outsider they would treat you the
same and what that meant was
invading your village or your tribe
killing as many people as they could
gruesomely scalping
taking scalps as as souvenirs any men
who were captured would automatically be
tortured to death
again standard operating procedure it
was just understood that's what they
would do
babies were automatically killed women
were gang-raped and then killed
um children were taken as uh as
enforceably adopted by the tribe
and this is just how it went for
centuries this is just what they did how
they operated
um and that's what the texas rangers
were up against and they themselves were
violent men it was a violent time
and everybody was violent um
but of course you know the texas rangers
were the undisputed bad guys
somehow even though they're up against
people who are doing some of the most
committing some of those brutally
horrific violent acts you could imagine
and even a lot of stuff you couldn't
possibly imagine
even though that's the case they're
still totally the bad guys 100
and the other side is entirely innocent
right
number five finally johnny depp i guess
is in divorce proceedings with his wife
amber heard
um and i you know i've seen these
headlines pop up i don't really care
except i i did see this i did care about
a little bit i saw this photo was
released today
shown in court it's johnny depp passed
out
covered in ice cream and this is
supposed to prove i don't know that he's
uh that he's a
monstrous figure i'm not sure i just
want to say in his defense
okay who has not fallen asleep covered
in ice cream
we haven't we all been there this is me
three times a week
i mean my wife definitely has found me
on the couch late at night with a plate
of food
asleep head hanging down like that and
the food just
falling off into my lap i'm not high i'm
not on drugs okay
i'm not drunk it's stone cold sober but
you know it happens
you go for the late night snack it's
midnight you're tired
and you fall asleep in the middle of
eating am i the only one maybe i am
maybe it's just me and johnny depp
also a slightly more serious note i
suppose i keep seeing these pictures of
johnny depp
in these compromising positions what
kind of
wife i have no dog in this fight at all
i don't even understand what the fight
is i mean it's a divorce okay i guess
that's pretty self-explanatory but
what kind of wife takes pictures of
their
husband like you you find your husband
in a compromised position
and you take a picture of him that's
your first reaction
you're really concerned about his health
and so you take pictures of him
and save those pictures and now you
bring him out in court yes
real loving and attentive life there uh
he had for himself i suppose
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description